on a vu vincent est un peu dépité et on
le comprend le secteur agricole qui a
bien du mal à attirer les nouvelles
générations la faute aux conditions de
travail et aux rémunérations deux
agriculteurs se suicident en france
chaque jour alors en fait ton assez pour
les agriculteurs français on attend vos
réactions sur notre compte télégramme et
place un autre décryptage
pour en parler sur ce plateau à thierry
pouch economista chef du service études
et prospectives de l'assemblée
permanente des chambres d'agriculture
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à nos
côtés également eric revel
éditorialistes désormais rt france
bonsoir eric rebelles est avec nous en
direct par skype christian fourcade
agriculteurs président de la fdsea
des hautes-pyrénées bonsoir à vous
également un mot tout d'abord sur le
reportage convient d'entendre vincent
qui dit qu'il est payé 36 centimes le
litre de lait contre un euro dans les
supermarchés thierry pouch comment vous
expliquer qu'on n'arrive pas à valoriser
la matière première des agriculteurs
alors que sur le marché les prix
explosent dans le cours de la farine a
pris 10% l'année dernière + 20 % pour le
prix du beurre et ce problème semble
récurrent depuis déjà des années oui
c'est qu'il ya un problème récurrent
comme vous dites
le prix du lait en plus a augmenté
depuis quelques mois la difficulté pour
cet éleveur c'est que ces coûts de
production ont eux sont sont aussi
alourdi ce qui fait que même si le prix
du lait a augmenté le prix des charges
qu'il enregistre et augmente aussi et
donc à la fin sa marge elle est
extrêmement réduite et il y à un autre
problème qui se pose dans l'agriculture
française c'est que ces augmentations de
charges on a du mal à les voir se
transmettre jusqu'au prix à la
consommation donc il ya effectivement un
problème de répercussions de ces charges
sur les prix à la consommation
et là évidemment ça renvoie à la loi et
galim 1 et la loi et galim 2 qui
manifestement dans certaines branches
s'applique fort mal alors justement
ainsi le consommateur paye 4 centimes de
plus et pas forcément à nous que ça va
revenir c'est ce qu'il dit les
organisations des productions c'est ce
que demande évidemment aussi la prison
de hull fns à christiane lambert qu'on
écoute
il est urgent de donner à l'agriculture
française les moyens de répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens l'acte de
production doit être valorisée en
mobilisant tous les outils il faut
arrêter les sur transposition des normes
par rapport aux directives européennes
escient fourcade alors c'est un problème
de norme où ce sont les grandes surfaces
qui ne jouent pas le jeu
c'est un ensemble de problèmes il ya les
deux ya les normes qui sont transposés
au niveau français c'est à dire que on a
des coûts de production différentes de
nos voisins européens
ce qui fait que ils nous prenaient des
marchés et on ne peut pas continuer de
vivre avec des prix qui sont pratiqués
et les charges surtout colonna et
ensuite on a des grandes surfaces qui
sort la tentaculaire qui représente de
80 % de la vente de produits
alimentaires dans ce pays ils sont
quatre et il faut la loire ils font ce
qu'ils veulent et la guerre des prix a
recommencé dernièrement avec la baguette
à 29 centimes mais ce n'est que le
prémice d'autre chose c'est que les
grandes surfaces aujourd'hui n'accepte
pas la loi la loi et galim 2 ils veulent
à tout prix faire en sorte de la dola
démonter avant qu'elle soit appliquée
eric revel c'est vrai que ce problème de
la rémunération des agriculteurs on en
parle maintenant depuis des années
d'accord avec monsieur foccart d'un
petit peu la faute aux grandes surfaces
qui sont pas toujours le jeu où c'est
plus compliqué que ça il ya aussi les
normes les normes européennes il ya les
normands p2 mais si vous voulez je pense
que c'est très bien résumé la loi et
gaylib dans gouvernement d'ailleurs
effet un peu le nec plus ultra de sa
politique à l'école c'est comme
clairement un échec pour l'instant il
faut connaître ya peut-être des produits
sur lesquels on paye à son juste prix
une production agricole mais il ya plein
d'exemples cet agriculteur a raison ou
ou c'est pas le cas malheureusement pour
un secteur qui est quand même plus
qu'important il est important pour
nourrir les français mais il est
important aussi parce qu'on l'oublié
dans le fiasco actuel du commerce
extérieur français c'est l'un des trois
postes qui qui est encore en excédent
commercial c'est l'agroalimentaire
français donc c'est pas n'importe quel
secteur à dax allemand oui ou non il est
important alors on importe évidemment
beaucoup de productions à l'école mais
parmi les secteurs qui quittent qui
dégage un excédent commercial vous avez
le spatial vous avez la pharmacie je
crois de mémoire et puis vous avez
l'agroalimentaire pour six ou sept
milliards d'euros par an versus un
déficit attendu comme de 95 milliards
d'euros pour l'ensemble du commerce
extérieur français en 2022 donc ce qui
est absolument incroyable si vous
laissez que finalement on ne s'occupe
des agriculteurs dans ce pays alors que
vous rappeliez le chiffre de la mutuelle
sociale agricole qui dit que deux
agriculteurs se suicident par jour on ne
s'occupe des agriculteurs dans ce pays
que quand il ya une élection
présidentielle et quand vous regardez
pardon le programme les programmes des
candidats aussi bien à gauche qu'à
droite vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de
propositions et puis un autre moment où
on s'en occupe et on s'y tient c'est la
plus grande ferme du monde ce moment du
salon de l'agriculture si ce qui va
avoir lieu fin février sinon on les
laisse se déplace bien sûr mais on les
laisse se dépatouiller voilà alors
évidemment tous les candidats vont vous
dire c'est un secteur vital pour la
france la france a besoin de ces
agriculteurs extra mais concrètement
quels jeunes va se lancer dans un métier
qui va lui demander de travailler dix
heures par jour 7 sur 7 jours sur 7 pour
lui rapporter 1100 ou ou à peine le smic
ses fins voilà et donc l'agriculture
française est dans cette situation là et
puis vous en parlerez sans doute
beaucoup mieux que moi il ya aussi cette
nouvelle politique agricole commune qui
est un autre sujet me semble-t-il de
préoccupation pour le monde agricole
alors est-ce qu'on est en fait assez
pour les agriculteurs c'était notre note
question du soir 1
je vous laisse regarder ces chiffres 1
605 suicide on en parlait à l'instant
chez les agriculteurs exploitants ou
salariés deux sujets par jour donc on me
disait 274 ont plus de 65 ans 4/5 ce
sont des hommes thierry pouch
pourquoi cette situation on oublie les
agriculteurs pendant l'année si j'ose
dire pendant les le quinquennat on s'en
souvient lors des campagnes électorales
vous vous l'expliquez comment vous
je suis pas certain qu'on les oublie
pendant toute une mandature
même si les deux lois et galim n'ont pas
répondu à une certaine attente les états
généraux de l'alimentation ont quand
même été instauré par le président mâcon
il s'agissait quand même l'objectif est
encore une fois l'objectif n'est pas
atteint mais il s'agissait quand même
d'inverser le processus de négociation
des prix il fallait que les agriculteurs
puissent décider de leur prix et les
proposer aux transformateurs et aux
distributeurs donc il s'agissait de
rééquilibrer en quelque sorte les
rapports de force au sein des filières
mais on voit bien c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce que comme lundi que le
président de la fdsea il ya une
concentration en aval et surtout dans la
grande distribution qui fait que l'on
peut mieux s'entendre quand on est peu
nombreux de quand on est plus nombreux
donc là c'est vraiment une difficulté
alors il ya des formes de contrats qui
marche plutôt bien on voit bien que sur
le lait ça commence à prendre forme mais
en revanche évidemment sur la viande
bovine c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
donc je crois que on les oublie pas
toujours pendant toute une mandature
mais il y à une autre question qui vient
d'être tendancieux revel c'est
évidemment l'union européenne on peut se
demander à travers toutes ces réformes
est celle qui va rentrer en application
au 1er janvier 2023 si ça va être
possible je ne sais pas trop mais on
peut se demander ce que veut faire
l'union européenne de son agriculture
dans un monde où il y as besoin de
nourriture justement on peut
s'interroger sur la stratégie
que va suivre l'union européenne alors
que tous les autres pays toutes les
grandes autres puissances agricoles
soutiennent assez massivement leurs
agriculteurs christian fourcade vous
souhaite vous ne vous sentez pas assez
soutenu clairement par par l'europe
l'agriculture française se portait mieux
avant l'europe ça remonte quand même
maintenant mais un ennemi ou un allié
pour vous
le leur or pour nous et une soutien
financier mais ses soutiens financiers a
complètement désorganisé notre
profession la problématique c'est que
derrière ce ce soutien financier il ya
une sur administration qui s'est mis en
place d'un titulaire qui a tous les
jours nous envoient des courriers et des
rappels pour savoir ce que l'on a fait
et pour la part de 1023 c'est à il est à
même de mettre au point un système de
satellites qui vont passer tous les deux
jours en moyenne trois jours celui sur
la france avec un des ordinateurs qui
vont traiter toutes ces photos et ils y
vont ils vont savoir
ce que l'on fait au jour le jour et on
va devoir
y voler les faire correspondre à nos
déclarations que l'on fait sur
ordinateur sur papier ce jeu suit ya
un système qui est en train de se mettre
en place qui est le big brother à la
façon de 1023 qui ne laisse aucune
initiative est un site vous avez déjà
sur le terrain dès la police comme des
romans qui viennent chez vous vous
apprendre votre métier et nous dire ah
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et comment il
faut faire et cette acquisition
environnementale c'est celle qui pèse le
plus et elle pèse le plus surtout sur
les petites exploitations qui n'ont pas
les moyens de se défendre ou d'avoir des
spécialistes pour contrebalancer ces
accusations et qui plus est aujourd'hui
sur louvain l'aquitaine est là voisine
chez moi on a mis un système qui ça fait
qu'ils s'appellent de dénonciation lors
de pratiques et anti stationnement pour
l'utilisation de produits jt sans terre
n'importe qui va pouvoir appeler un site
internet pour dénoncer la pratique d'un
art et culture locale mam son voisin une
suite
ce sont des pratiques qui sont avalisées
par le ministère de la santé le
ministère la mire au noma mme lemay
serriculture attend d'elle peut être
aujourd'hui de faire marche arrière mais
ce qu'on voit c'est que il ya une
ambiance délétère qui est en train de se
mettre en place dans nos campagnes on ne
sera plus à l'abri de deux voisins
religion ou pour ce soir car on m'a
lâché löw va carrément va étendre fumier
ou quand on va faire un traitement
phytosanitaire
ça devient assez important et est très
large et très pesante eric revel ya
plusieurs choses dans ce que nous dit
monsieur on parlait des normands ben un
soutien financier mais en même temps
quelle vert de paperasse administrative
ça c'est pas le seul il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises françaises qui croule sous
sous l'administration et s'en plaignent
encore malgré le mandat macron qui avait
promis un allègement il ya aussi la
question voilà des mentalités peut-être
qui change dans les campagnes peut-être
voilà les personnes peut-être l'exode
urbaine qui côtoie la campagne ça se
passe pas toujours bien c'est ce que
nous disait d'ailleurs ce témoin dont
qu'en pensent les français ce soir
freedhoff d'abord j'aimerais applaudir
la lucidité à la franchise de ce
représentants du monde agricole parce
que c'est vrai que l'agriculture
française est quand même tombé dans le
piège j'allais dire de entre guillemets
l'argent facile qui est tombé de la
politique agricole commune et qui a
entraîné des évolutions parfois
sonnantes et trébuchantes forcément
qu'on peut regretter aujourd'hui mais je
dirais que cette année me semble-t-il
est assez particulière pour le monde
agricole parce que au delà de cette pac
2023 au delà de cette loi et galim 2 qui
tarde à être mise en place et assurer
des prix minimums aux agriculteurs il ya
aussi des factures qu'on culturelle qui
se sont
accumulés je veux parler par exemple du
grand gel qui a eu lieu l'an passé qui a
touché le monde arboricole le monde
agricole le monde viticole et on voit
bien que une partie aussi de la grogne
qu'on voit ressurgir à nîmes à lamballe
à tarbes ces derniers jours avec des
défilés de tracteurs il est dû aussi au
fait que ces aides qui devait assurer à
ceux qui on perd tout perdu avec ces
gels et bach sesay de trent rennes et ne
sont pas toujours versée il ya un autre
facteur qui est conjoncturelle mais qui
devient structurelle on a aussi poussé
beaucoup hein les agriculteurs à faire
du bio et on s'aperçoit que la demande
de bio n'est pas forcément au rendez
vous savez c'est un peu comme les
conducteurs à qui on a dit prenez plutôt
de voitures diesel une voiture à essence
on va vous faire des prix et puis
ensuite on leur explique que le diesel
il a pu polluer qui va falloir se
séparer de 110 elle est bien les
agriculteurs on les a aussi parfois
poussé me semble utile dans le bio avec
une demande des consommateurs qui est
pas forcément au rendez vous donc on se
retrouve avec des produits bio qui sont
parfois plus cher que d'autres mais la
demande ne suit pas donc ces facteurs
structurels plus me semble-t-il quelques
facteurs conjoncturels explique à mon
sens beaucoup de la résurgence de la
grogne à quel on assiste dans nos
campagnes en bretagne ou dans le sud de
la france alors quelques réactions
télégramme un pierrot qui nous écrit un
instant les gars qui nous permettent de
manger sont exploitées il faut tout
revoir thierry pouch le monde à
maquereau est ce qu'il a changé quelque
chose pour les agriculteurs à en parler
de ce choc de simplification est ce que
on a vu que c'était leur dédain des
principaux problèmes aussi des
exploitations ya du mieux quand même la
tentative de d'établir un nouveau
un nouvel équilibre entre les acteurs
des filières étaient probablement une
bonne ambitions la difficulté c'est que
dès la loi égalise 1 1 on n'a pas pu
atteindre les objectifs parce que les
rapports de force était trop profond
d'où la proposition d'un député
de de faire une deuxième loi avec
l'intégration des coûts de production
donc ça aussi mais on voit bien
aujourd'hui que ça a du mal à se mettre
en place et que comme le disait monsieur
revel il ya eu tout un accumulation de
paramètres qu'on n'avait pas
véritablement anticipé des problèmes de
tension sur les prix internationaux les
répercussions des prix énergétiques sur
le prix des engrais on a un certain
nombre d'agriculteurs aujourd'hui qui ne
trouve même plus d'engrais parce que ça
se raréfient et ils sont excessivement
chers bon plus évidemment la réforme de
la pac qui va se mettre en place en 2023
avec quand même deux années de retard du
fait des négociations avec le break site
plus les difficultés que les états
membres ont eu pour se mettre d'accord
autour d'un budget donc tout ça ça a
fait que finalement l'espèce de
confiance qui s'était instaurée entre le
ministre et le monde agricole c'est un
peu fissuré au gré des semaines et la
crise sanitaire évidemment n'a pas
arrangé les choses puisque on vient de
voir que sur le bio par exemple
effectivement la demande n'est plus au
rendez vous donc il ya un faisceau de
paramètres là qui convergent pour mettre
en grande difficulté le monde agricole
et là il ya une nécessité non pas
seulement d'en parler ou au nom d'une
campagne électorale mais d'agir sur la
longue période enfin on imagine que vous
allez tous observé cette campagne et les
propositions des candidats avec
attention de sergent prend une yannick
jadot sur
l'europe écologie les verts qui veut
interdire l'élevage industriel d'ici dix
ans pardon et 2025 bcc dans pas
longtemps mara et glyphosate aussi
interdit quasiment du jour au lendemain
mais à 2 heures du matin en catimini moi
je suis pas un expert du monde agricole
mais cette affaire d'engrais au delà du
fait que les prix ont énormément
augmenté comme vous le disiez parce que
toutes les matières premières avec cette
économie mondiale qui redémarre elles
ont été demandés en même temps donc en
vous un problème d'offre et de demande
rien de demande forte et clov suis pas
les prix augmentent mais demandez un
agriculteur ceux
enlevés les engrais de ces cultures ou
de ses chances ça se fait pas sur un
claquement de doigts et surtout ça d
impact terrible pour la production c'est
pas si simple que de dire vos engrais
polluer faut lui enlever l'est et et
tout ira mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes c'est une vie république et il ya
beaucoup de déclarations d'intention
comme celle ci a effectivement
l'interdiction de l'élevage industriel
c'est applicable tout ça vous ressentez
quoi quand vous vous voyez ce genre de
propositions de la part des différents
candidats et notamment là en
l'occurrence ou yannick jadot christian
fourcade
est un candidat hors sol il n'a vécu que
dans sa ville n'a jamais su ce que
c'était de travailler la terre et lille
à son idéologie est totalement
artificielle
chaque fois qu'ils s'étaient
amusés à part les agriculteurs et cetera
- ses cordes parce qu'il n'a aucune
compétence en la matière seraient que
des idéologies mais le problème c'est
que ces gens là ont fait rentrer dans
toute l'administration française des
fonctionnaires à
idéologisé qui travaille pour une
écologie non plus pour l'état et qui
passent leur journée à m et à chercher
des contraintes supplémentaires à m pour
les agriculteurs pasteurs ils ont
noyauté ses amarres noyauté même avec
quelque 5% de votes ils ont pour elles
étaient tous les tous leurs appareils de
fonctionnaires et on a en face tout le
temps sans arrêt ces gens-là du
département jusqu'à jusqu'à paris
dans les halles face et ces gens là
utilisent et ils usent et abusent de
leur autorité sur lui pour l'obliger
nous écoeurer de certaines pratiques qui
pour eux idéologiquement ne sont pas
bonnes mains et on les a tous les jours
de la lho il ya une autre proposition
qui a peu à mi chemin entre
l'agriculture et l'environnement qu'une
proposition de jean luc mélenchon qui
est d'interdire la chasse bon ben ça
veut dire qu' il ne connaît pas lui non
plus le monde à l'école parce que déjà
on en a beaucoup de problèmes avec le
gros gibier et voyez avec les sangliers
en france on sait plus quoi faire avec
les cheuvreux qui sont bagués par l'eau
nf l'office national des forêts est en
fait tous au gros gibier il détruit
aussi des hagrid et des territoires
agricoles c'est un problème de sécurité
publique imaginez simplement si du jour
au lendemain la chasse est interdite ce
qui va se passer dans les champs de maïs
qui va se passer sur les routes mais je
pense que dans le programme de mélenchon
c'est de bon ton de dire oui je suis
contre la souffrance animale donc j'ai
interdit la chasse mais pardon c'est
sans doute pas connaître grand chose est
ce qui se passe dans nos forêts dans nos
champs thierry pouch comme le dit eric
revel et est question fourcade des
candidats pour la plupart hors sol il ya
un grand malaise on est loin de 2
jacques chirac qu'elle est le
pardonnez-moi tâter le cul des vaches
selon l'expression consacrée au salon de
l'agriculture c'est vrai que ça manque
peut-être de candidats de dépaysant
lors de cette campagne 2022
que vous répondre je suis fin je je je
sors de mon champ de compétences du coup
mais je hais ce qu' il faut qu'un
ministre soit agriculteurs pour faire un
bon ministre je n'ai pas d'éléments de
réponse moi ce que je constate c'est que
il y a une grande difficulté du côté du
secteur agricole ce secteur a pourtant
des atouts ça a été rappelé en termes de
commerce extérieur par exemple parce que
depuis trois ans à l'exception de
l'année 2020 pour des raisons que l'on
connaît le commerce extérieur s'est
redressée on va être pour l'année 2000
21 plus très loin des 9 10 milliards
d'excédents donc c'est au dessus on
était plutôt à 7 donc il ya eu un
redressement donc je crois que
indépendamment des programmes électoraux
il ya aussi tout un
un raisonnement tout une prise en compte
sur les atouts que représente ce secteur
agricole non seulement pour nourrir la
population mais aussi pour répondre à
une demande mondiale qui nous est
adressé en particulier celles qui
émanent des pays tiers il ya tout un
savoir faire des agriculteurs qu'il faut
valoriser il ya toute une histoire donc
ça c'est on ne part pas de rien on est
une des plus grandes puissances
agricoles mondiales et on est la
première puissance agricole européenne
donc de ce point de vue là il faut aussi
rappeler ces éléments positifs
même s'il ya une crise profonde il faut
la régler il faut que les négociations
se poursuivre il faut essayer de
convaincre les transformateurs et les
distributeurs de répercuter la hausse
des charges des agriculteurs et je crois
que ça va au delà du seul périmètre
électoral merci en tout cas à tous les
trois thierry pouch christian fourcade
eric revel